Steve have you found that your
philanthropy is more effective when done
independent of government programs I
think most the philanthropy needs to be
focused on getting government programs
to actually work better to stimulate
brighter ideas grateful yes the bulk of
the money comes from government we got
to make sure it gets used really well
some things you know the only government
could win world war ii and i think only
government can solve the environmental
crisis i just don't think that's
something what do you think about your
fellow billionaires who want to go to
mars
[Laughter]
okay let's see well anyone in this
administration ever be held accountable
for the separation of immigrant children
and the abuse they are enduring well
accountability is a tough thing to come
by lately but i hope so probably not no
and it's appalling it's appalling and
that it is suddenly politically
courageous to come up and say that
that's a bad thing
babies in cages yeah probably really
disappointing glad we're all in
agreeance on that what's your advice
richard clark to the next president on
how to respond to russia's ongoing
attacks if you had your old job so
there's a building in saint-petersburg
called the internet research agency
which is in fact a front for the russian
intelligence service that's where all
their trolls are that's where all their
trouble not all of them but a lot of
them are and they're still doing it
every day I would try every computer in
that building we have the capability
really yeah we could do that Marx with a
push of a button tomorrow we look why
don't we do so why don't we do it
because you know well they'd replace
them the next day maybe but I'd feel
well wouldn't they do too
when they give it to us no they're
already doing pretty much everything
they could do to us they're in our power
grid they're in the pipeline controls
lift they're if they're in our power
grid couldn't they couldn't they freeze
our computers do yeah they can yeah we
can't be self-determined what do you
know about computers right 43 play ok
you recently held a shareholder meeting
Steve for American taxpayers do you
think the government should run like a
corporation that's interesting because
when people elected Trump they were like
yeah we need a business minister
president this is more than much the
kind of the businessmen I think we
should have is prison what I think we
need is we need somebody who's got the
discipline in thinking things through in
knowing numbers and using data we're not
trying to maximize profit or you know
exactly I believe in balancing the
budget but it's not all about that it's
about the outcomes and using numbers and
being systematic and you know with us
apex we welcome anybody in a country to
use our data
I mean profit ich ins when they run for
office they always write a dumb book you
know oh this is and that's my platform
it seems like us a fax data is a much
better platform than a dumb book if say
you wanted to run you could say this is
I've already done the work I already
know what to do to fix America and I'll
tell you something we just finished
something we call the state of the fax
poll we go out and pull on this stuff
Americans want the facts look you've got
that you got that values they want us
they'll say we want to stop United you
don't want to be a politician no so
here's I want to stay married and I like
I like I like right yeah you want to
stay mad yeah my wife doesn't like the
idea politician
this way I think I can probably do more
and stay married to my very lovely wife
see here's what I'm thinking when you're
saying this I love them the fact that I
need to start talking louder because I
think I don't want to be the quiet ball
right no you're great I wouldn't change
a thing yeah but but what happens when
you have these objective política
politifact like things is that whenever
something comes out that one side
disagrees with ie
you know Republicans think that like
politifact all these fact-checking
things or the Congressional Budget
Office or they oh it's partisan what do
you say when the inevitable oh that
thing's partisan because they don't like
the numbers comes out we don't make
forecasts forecasts are partisan what
happened happened what happened we know
how many people are covered by health
care I won't predict what goes forward
we know how many people died in a what
age last year we won't make forecasts
forecasts are and be partisan the
history geez we can't even look back and
objectively say that is what happened
and accept it what we need to my god
there's more than said you can have your
own opinions but you can have your own
facts and we know what happened and I
think it is disgusting when people so
just ignore the number no for like
testing for attack
how how the Clippers gonna do this year
we're gonna win a lot of games
that's a forecast okay final question SE
Cupp do you regret your write-in vote
for Paul Ryan in 26 days not voting for
my party's nominee I don't regret that
and I'm challenged on that all the time
and yeah of course but I don't regret
that with every day I am proven I think
right in in that in that vote for me it
was not for me it don't really help no
it did there's only to me there's only
two parties only two people running it
seems like I couldn't vote for either
but I can't clip my son in 20 years
Hillary was that awful oh yeah
Hillary was was gonna be anywhere near
as bad as Trump was well I can't
forecast but she was a terrible terrible
candidate candidate yes not president
would she have been a terrible president
I think very based on past it close to
how terrible Trump is well that's a high
bar okay so but mature people make
assessments and one thing is always
better than the other isn't it
irresponsibility to pick that out hold
your nose and do the right thing I did
not think one thing was better than do
you now really you've seen Trump for
almost two years and you think Hillary
could have possibly had been this bad in
different ways yeah I think she could
have oh like what was like what would
she have done that would be the
magnitude I know and that's the problem
but we're right on the problem no no
part of it part of it hey you know what
when I voted for Nader I copped to it I
said I was wrong you believed that I
don't believe I was sorry okay
but no I'm just asking you what would
Hillary what could Hillary have possibly
done that that would be as bad as Trump
has been I think that she's deceptive
and unaccountable in ways that people
don't completely acknowledge don't know
we have that now it's awful but not
really as deceptive okay you can judge
me you can that's the person who is told
five thousand wives
I don't regret not voting for other crap
okay that question no not a bit you have
stood up to my withering category-five
president thank you everybody gets tired
[Applause]